you are in some serious mood to have ice
cream and you have three options to
choose from
chocolate butterscotch and vanilla
let's just refer to them as c b and v
say you can have only one kind of ice
cream at a time
it means you can have either chocolate
or butterscotch or vanilla
that was simple but what if you feel
like having two at a time
what are the different possibilities
you can have chocolate and butterscotch
together
or you may want chocolate and vanilla
is there any other combination possible
yes you could also have butterscotch and
vanilla together
in each of these scenarios three sets
were formed
each of these sets is a different
possibility
but what if you feel like having all
three together
there exists only one possibility in
this case
a combination of chocolate butterscotch
and vanilla
and here's one scenario nobody wants to
be in
if you are unwell and the doctor has
advised you against having any ice cream
in that case what we have is an empty
set
you have none of
these don't forget the original set we
were looking at
the original set was chocolate
butterscotch and vanilla
this is the set of all kinds of ice
cream we could choose from
the most important thing we need to
understand is that all the sets on the
right are a part of this main set
yes each set here is a part of this set
and in mathematics we say that each set
is a subset of the main set
it's a little easier to visualize these
sets to be a part of the main set
c is a part of cbv
cv is a part of cbv
or bv is a part of cbv
but we should also know that the empty
set is also the subset of the entire set
nothing is a part of this entire thing
and this entire set is also a subset of
this entire set
we will understand these concepts in
much more detail in the coming videos
for now just remember that a subset
means part of another set
you